guardians of the galaxy vol 2 T's is an
awesome new character we can look
forward to seeing in the future Marvel
cosmic universe including guardians vol
3 the final movie and James Gunn's
trilogy UK movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to explain
and breakdown what the end credits tease
of the comic book character Adam warlock
means for potential storylines in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and also
Avengers 4 don't forget my guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 giveaway is also
running here and for a chance to win
just subscribe and leave a comment on
this video and we'll be full details
about the giveaway and prizes at the end
obviously there are spoilers ahead for
guardians volume 2 and speculation about
the future MCU so if you prefer a
spoiler free video you can tap in the
top right of the screen for my guardians
to movie review let's start with a brief
reminder as amid credit scene which
opens with Aisha the High Priestess of
the sovereign race sitting slumped in
front of a wall of gold birthing pods
Aisha reveals that she created the next
step in the sovereigns evolution of
being more powerful more beautiful more
capable of destroying the guardians of
the galaxy who she says she'll call Adam
all of which is a huge tease for Adam
warlock appearing in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 by the way Adams birthing
pod in this scene has some similarity to
the cocoon we saw with the collector in
the first guardians movie and which many
people at the time thought could have
been an Adam warlock Easter Egg this
time around though the pod definitely is
a nod to the cocoon in which the gold
skinned Adam warlock was formed in the
comics warlock was created in Fantastic
Four issue 66 by a group of scientists
called the enclaves who sought to
genetically engineer a perfect race of
human beings that could rule over the
world
initially the character had no name and
was only referred to as him and I liked
the movie subtle call-out to that fact
when Aisha says I think I shall call him
Adam I should think she's created a
powerful antagonist to the guardians of
the galaxy but I wonder if she might get
a nasty surprise when Adam finally
emerges from his birthing pod as in the
comics Adams creators were also going to
manipulate him to do their bidding but
that did not end well for them as he
didn't like the nefarious plans and
escaped pretty sharpish leaving behind a
scene of devastation on the other hand
it's possible that when Adam appears
properly in the
next Guardians movie you'll feel a kind
of kinship or connection with Aisha
because they've both been created in
birthing pods and designed to be
physically and mentally impeccable as
all the sovereign people are by the way
in the comics like Adam warlock Aisha
was also created by the enclaves group
of scientists and lashed out against
them her comic book backstories rather
complicated but suffice to say that in
one of her early forms she was also
known as her before taking on the name
of kismet and later Aisha
okay getting back to Adam warlock in the
comics later he becomes a member of the
guardians of the galaxy however in the
MCU it looks like it's being set up to
work with Aisha as an antagonist to the
Guardians which is intriguing because in
the comics is an evil version of Adam
warlock known as Omega the Magus is
actually a God who is worshipped by the
universal Church of truth and I think
there's a really interesting link here
with the MCU Aisha who is the High
Priestess as a sovereign race so because
the sovereign actually be the MC you'd
own take on the universal Church of
Truth the intolerant religious sect that
went on an expansionist rampage
throughout the comic book universe and
could the film's version of Aisha play a
similar role for matriarch who is a
leader of the church in the comics I'd
love to know your thoughts on that in
the comics the guardians of the galaxy
stood up against the church they perhaps
this could be a future storyline will
see in guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and
I wonder whether there's also a
potential link to another cosmic dark
force in the MCU that is Dormammu and
the doct I mention which was introduced
in the Doctor Strange movie it'll be
fascinating to see if they connect these
earth now one of the major comic book
storylines that Adam warlock is crucial
to is the Infinity Gauntlet and in
particular he has a very strong
connection to the soul gem in the comics
it's a complicated and lengthy story
which involves masses of marvel's heroes
warlock included joining forces against
Sun off but one of the highlights is
that Adam warlock not only wields the
gauntlet himself he also puts together
the infinity watch which was basically
individuals who each protected one of
the infinity gems if you're thinking
this means we'll get Adam warlock
introducing the soul stone in or before
Avengers infinity war this is sadly very
unlikely because James Gunn doesn't plan
to introduce the character until
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 which
takes place after the
moving gun has said so this is Guardians
volume three is happening after the
culmination of Marvel's phase 3 the
third guardians movie will launch both
new and old Marvel characters into the
next ten years and beyond and there are
big plans ahead for the character of
Adam warlock in the Marvel cosmic
universe speaking of which a comment by
Zoe Saldana who plays Gamora suggested
that Avengers 4 which is the next
Avengers movie after infinity war maybe
titled Infinity Gauntlet so given atom
war lot of connections to the Infinity
Gauntlet in the comics could he pop up
an Avengers 4 not if we take James Gunn
at his word at these tweeted that
guardians vol 3 will take place after
Avengers 4 as well at this point it
seems likely that Avengers infinity war
will feature Sun of gathering the
Infinity stones to unite them all in the
gauntlet by the end of the movie facing
opposition from marvel's heroes along
the way after all we did see standoff
real the gauntlet complete with all the
Infinity stones and a promo Marvel
released in 2014 according to Kevin
Feige the MCU standoffs a similar motive
to his comic book counterpart in the
comics Alice's desire to wield the
Infinity Gauntlet is tied up with his
desire to impress mistress death who he
adores by the way it wouldn't surprise
me as Marvel decide to youth goddess of
death Heller who's played by Cate
Blanchett with a suitable substitute to
save introducing the comic book
character mistress death in The Avengers
movies so Avengers 4 could find Stan off
wielding the power of the gauntlet and
also still battling Marvel's heroes
hence it's rumored subtitle Infinity
Gauntlet
as in the comics a Knopf used the
gauntlet to obliterate half the
population in the universe for mistress
death it would seem a shame given Adam
warlocks history with the infinity gems
in the comics if he had no role
whatsoever in getting the Infinity
stones back from Thanos or if he wasn't
put in charge of safekeeping the
gauntlets in the stones as he did by
forming the Infinity watch in the comics
so a year excited to see Adam warlock
joining the Marvel cosmic universe do
you have any theories on how he could
fit into the guardians with galaxy vol 3
and the rest of the MCU and who would
you like to see cast in the role don't
forget to comment and subscribe to enter
my guardians to give away the prizes
include two awesome hardback books from
DK guardians of the galaxy the ultimate
guide to the cosmic outlaws which take
an in-depth look at iconic characters
issues and storylines from the comics
and I've also got the selection of three
very cool Guardians Funko pop vinyl
figures so make sure you hit the bell to
turn on notifications so you stay up to
date with all my new videos and if you
enjoyed this video do hit that thumbs up
button and check out more of my
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and Marvel
videos right here thanks for watching
and see you next time
epic a movie lovers